in our continuing series pushing the
limits we focus on ordinary people doing
extraordinary things today we look at an
athletic feat that is both inspirational
and incredible CBS this morning Saturday
co-host Michelle Miller is here with the
story of a cycling team called c2c
Michelle good morning good morning they
are extraordinary imagine how hard it
would be to race across the country more
than 3,000 miles on a bicycle now
imagine doing that on a bicycle built
for two and oh by the way the rider in
the back is blind
that's what team c2c did and for one
rider it helped fulfill her desire to be
the eyes for others
Carolyn Gaynor was all smiles as she
helped blind athlete Randy strut
complete the Texas Ironman triathlon
last spring I love incredibly long
endurance challenges but to me the
motivating factor is I love guiding
blind and visually impaired athletes
that's the thing that keeps me training
every day but while she was swimming
biking and running with Randy's future
teammates were nearly a thousand miles
away training for an even more rigorous
competition team c2 c4 tandem bikes
eight athletes four of them blind was
getting ready for the race across
America a cycling challenge from the
west coast to the east the team was the
concept of two visually impaired
athletes Jack Chen and Dan Berlin we
both feel like we wanted to demonstrate
to the world that people who are blind
can be extraordinarily successful
because that message just does not get
out enough so your visual impairments
just just a minor detail in this story
right to us yes we never gave it a
second thought Jackie and Carolyn are
one of the four tandem teams riding
together for the first time just a month
before the big race Carolyn who works
with financial advisors and her day job
upfront and is the pilot Jack a father
of two and a lawyer at Google sits in
the back and is known as the stoker so
how do you know this is gonna work it's
just going to work I I trust and believe
that Jack and I can make this work my
goal is to keep whatever cadence Jack
prefers all right on a chilly June
morning in Oceanside California it was
time to race and for Team C to C to face
challenges beyond their imaginations
it's learning those lessons and
overcoming those insane obstacles that
really make you more resilient in life
generally and so I'm excited to get past
the dark times it's a real test of what
your ability is to to go beyond your own
your own boundaries absolutely and then
they walk
[Applause]
[Music]
Carolyn documented the obstacles and
triumphs along the way the race is more
than 3,000 miles challenging riders with
changing terrains and weather from
California to Annapolis Maryland Jack
and I just finished a ride I feel good
the scariest part was cross wind didn't
know when it was gonna happen
it was like a hidden ghost was just
smashing into the side of the bike and
let me tell you Missouri is hilly and
it's windy and there's traffic and I'm
eating Funyuns and they're amazing near
the end of the race in West Virginia
torrential rains forced Carolyn and Jack
to carry their bike at night through
floodwaters
but in the end 7 days 15 hours and 3
minutes after they began teams c2c
crossed the finish line where an
emotional and exhausted Carolyn fell
into her husband's waiting arms any race
it essentially almost breaks me is one
that I think is worth doing because
that's how you grow
and you can see this was not an easy
feat and that's what the visually
impaired when people know they can do
things like anybody else there are 30%
of the visually impaired community is
fully employed they want them out there
and they want employers to know that you
know what here the physicality of the
task at hand and they can do it oh my
gosh it's amazing to see them go through
that and having to pick up the bike and
walk into that water
no I but I like Jack's attitude guys
whirring you said is it going to work
it's just gonna work why cuz it's just
got a dad got to know jack either he's a
can-do guy really CSEA jsce
that's right it's great see the see
thank god oh